some of these authors have appeared on
book tv and you can watch them online at
booktv.org
good evening virtual audience and
welcome thank you so much for joining us
tonight my name is hillary carr and on
behalf of harvard bookstore i'm very
pleased to introduce this event with
nicholson baker presenting his new book
baseless my search for for secrets in
the ruins of the freedom of information
act joined in conversation by
christopher lydon
thank you for joining us tonight through
virtual events like tonight's harvard
bookstore continues to bring authors and
their work to our community and our new
digital community during these
unprecedented times every week we'll be
hosting events here on our zoom account
as always our event schedule also
appears on our website at harvard.com
events where you can sign up for our
email newsletter and browse our
bookshelves from home
this evening's discussion will conclude
with some time for your questions if you
have a question for our speakers at any
time during the talk tonight click on
the q a button at the bottom of the
screen and we'll get through as many as
time allows
um in the chat i'll be posting a link to
purchasebaselessonharvard.com as well as
a link to to donate in support of this
series and our store your purchases and
financial contributions make events like
tonight's possible and help ensure the
future of a landmark independent
bookstore
thank you so much for showing up and
tuning in in support of our authors and
the incredible staff of booksellers at
harvard bookstore
we sincerely appreciate your support now
and always
and finally as you may have experienced
in virtual gatherings these last few
weeks months
technical issues may arise
if they do we'll do our best to resolve
them quickly and we thank you for your
patience and understanding
and now i'm so pleased to introduce
tonight's speakers
nicholson baker is the best-selling
author of ten novels and numerous works
of non-fiction including the anthologist
the mezzanine human smoke substitute
going to school with a thousand kids and
the new york times best new york times
best-selling house of holes uh he's won
the national book national uh critics
circle award
the hermann hess prize and a catherine
anne porter award from the american
academy of arts and letters tonight he
will be joined by journalist and host of
wbur's open source christopher lyden
they'll be discussing nicholson's latest
book baseless and which publishers
weekly described as a colorful and
grossing recreation of sinister history
of a sinister history a convincing case
for opening government archives to
public scrutiny and the seattle times
called it a genre transforming blend of
history and memoir offering
behind-the-scenes glimpses of baker's
research efforts his home life and his
worst fears about his own country
that makes baseless essential reading
for anyone trying to grapple with the
role of the us in global affairs since
the end of world war ii we're so happy
to have them both here tonight so
without further ado the digital podium
is yours christopher and nicholson
hillary thank you and uh it's almost as
much fun as being in the harvard
bookstore uh thank you for inviting me
nicholson baker is
a friend and we've had this kind of
conversation
actually quite a number of times before
and it's always an education for me um
let me just say uh
i don't really need to introduce nick
baker to this audience but
i think of him as really uh he writes
three kinds of books one is the what i
would call sort of uh
uh photo realist prose my newt
about small things including shoelaces
his most famous opening book but then
there's also his
his childlike dare i say uh but very
grown up interested in sex
uh as in vox uh but then there is
a special category and this book uh
baseless is his masterpiece in it
uh what's to say non-fiction
sort of polemical history in a certain
way but history has never written
uh
i wouldn't say never but it's a it's a
method of looking at history how's to
describe it it is anti-imperial it is
anti-triumphal it is
anti-churchillian it is not the grand
scope of how
the english-speaking nations took over
the absolute
total universe or all that it's
pointillistic it's miniature it's
intimate
uh and at the center of it always is
this incredibly self-conscious vaguely
knowledge
uh consciousness modern consciousness in
a nightmarish world and this
this genre in the nicholson baker world
is my favorite human smoke
preceded it a sort of pacifist history
of world war ii an incredibly moving
book uh both in substance and in the way
he went about it but uh having said all
that
uh speak as you have with me before nick
of this as a
it's a kind of detective story it's a
story of a reporter's story but it's
also
um
at the highest level a writer's diary up
there with dostoevsky's diaries and and
all the great writers
most intimate diaries
yes well
first of all i want to say hello to
everybody and thank you for tuning in
it's amazing to me that these things can
happen and that
a bunch of people 60 people are are here
i can't see you but i'm so happy that
you're here a good crowd at the harvard
bookstore yes i the harvard bookstore um
was is one of those
places in my memory that's
i can remember individual books that
i've bought there and i i remember
buying
edmond goss's father and son
down in the in the basement there and
where the where the it's just it's just
a it's a place that has a particular
flavor and i love the bookstore and i'm
just
happy to be a part of it even if i'm not
in the bookstore
um
i
was trying to write about something that
happened a long time ago in this book
and
um
but it just occurred to me that
since i didn't know everything about
what happened a long time ago because
the documents were being withheld
that i would write about what was
happening while i was trying to write
about what happened a long time ago so
i
i ended up instead of having one
timeline which is the timeline of the
early cold war harry truman
korea
china
a gathering sense of suspicion and
paranoia i also was i wanted to write
about my own life as i was trying to
make sense of that early period so just
so happened amazingly and wonderfully
that my wife and i got to
uh rescue dachshunds the day before i
think was the day before i
i i started this i sort of it was like a
clapper
scene start the scene so i started the
book but it happened that we had gotten
too
very
difficult but very lovable dogs the day
before so
they kind of accompanied me through it
and ended up being very important to the
story
so it's a book about trying to write a
book about
what happened a long time ago
a lot of stuff i didn't know or had
forgotten that george kennan
of the famous x letter defining the cold
war was deep into this story um alan
dulles seemed to have put
one of the main players uh frank wisner
senior
into the job to chase to think up new
weapons um
harry truman was more involved than he
and he suggested later he had been in
cia dirty tricks et cetera et cetera
who are the main players that a lot of
people remember including henry cabot
live later but uh
i think uh
bush famous
monster scientist i mean a huge figure
president of mit i can see him on the
cover of time magazine i must have been
a kid or something but
this cast of characters post-war
we have not uh
post-war but entering formally
consciously along cold war with russia
i mean set us back there well
vanivar bush was was one of the more
famous and
fascinating characters of the time time
uh or life or somebody said that he
looked like ichabod crane he kind of had
a shock of hair he was a very intense
guy he liked to carve pipes
and give them to he gave a carved pipe
to alan dulles he
he to the people he really admired he
would give a pipe
he was a
tremendously powerful figure at mit
and he was in charge of the atom bomb
project in world war ii but he was also
in charge of the biological warfare
project and that's where it all began
was in world war ii so it just so
happened that after the war was over
he stayed on in the government and he
started to
because he was
deeply deeply suspicious and unhappy
about the russians
he
decided that what was important to do
was to ramp up the germ warfare program
in the united states in order to triumph
over the numerical superiority of the
russian army
with germs and that was his his solution
to the cold war was to
make
russian plants sick and russian people
sick
and it was a really bad idea actually
was he ever really explicit that we
can't beat them on the ground in human
force we've got to have something else
that was a refrain that was repeated
over and over by the secretaries of
defense by by all the people in the
pentagon they were immense they were
aware every minute of every day that if
we tried to fight that the chinese
armies
and the russian armies and the east
german armies that we were going to lose
and therefore we had to come up with it
as a smarter
solution a new kind of weapon because by
1949 the russians had developed an
atomic bomb so there was parity there
so what were we going to
do what what what how would we win this
war that
um seemed to be in the offing it was
going to happen in 1952 they thought and
then they sort of rescheduled it for
1954.
but it especially became
worrisome when the korean war itself
started it was a war that
was not called a war by harry truman but
because there had been an artificial
line drawn across the country of korea
by
two functionaries meeting in the
pentagon
the north became
communist inflected in the south became
uh an ally of the united states and
therefore there was a sort of
polarization
and it became in the united states
became involved in a civil war in korea
and as soon as that happened it was as
it was as if there was an electric shock
that went through washington and
everything that had just been plans and
schemes and worries in a general way
about the evil empire of russia suddenly
became very specific
and there were and especially when the
united states started losing
there was a feeling that well the
russian tanks were better than the
american tanks for instance and things
like
very concrete things started questions
started to be asked and the main
question was
what do we have
what do we have in our arsenal that will
win this apocalyptic war that's just
around the corner
there are two i
i would say two
very specific questions that you ask in
this search um
and one is did they actually put all
these bugs and and
uh chemical agents together we knew they
lusted for it but did they actually ever
have
the serum or whatever it was going to be
and secondly the more the final smoking
gun question did they ever use it they
have never
they never quite denied that they wanted
to find something or and they were
working on it they were commissioning
scientists to build it
but they've always denied that they
never used it the chief chief of the
government in north korea also china
eventually
accused the united states of planting
smallpox during that war
but
get to that fundamental question did we
or didn't we did we have it and did we
use it
well unfortunately i think the the
answer the short answer is yes
um
the
the chinese
and the north koreans
were very serious when they brought
these charges they they sent a cable to
the united nations it wasn't something
they just did casually one day and
thought this would be a nice thing to
say it was a very
serious set of charges and what they
said initially was that in november of
1950 when the americans fled to the
south of korea after a massive defeat
after the chinese counter-attack
that the
americans had left behind diseases
and then
uh the americans said that's ridiculous
and silly and of course we didn't do
that and then several months later a
mysterious new disease appeared in north
korea called hemorrhagic korean
hemorrhagic fever or epidemic
hemorrhagic fever and it was it existed
in a series of little dots along the
belt of korea along the 38th parallel
which mystified the american
epidemiologists so
that i think actually happened
then there was a second
a massive propaganda battle between the
communists and the anti-communists the
americans and the british and the
uh french and and that that
battle
what
hinged on whether
the americans
had flown over individual airplanes and
dropped mysterious
insect bombs if you can believe it
on
in the snow
of
the
the way the very
rural areas of china near the korean
border
and that i think is
has a slightly different answer and it
hinges on the book's title the book's
title is baseless the reason it's called
baseless is because operation baseless
was the name of an a secret top-secret
air force program that aimed to
perfect biological and chemical weapons
at the earliest possible date and it was
a a project that sprang into motion on
an emergency basis
as the korean war be
got bigger and became more
uh
well just everything got worse in korea
so project baseless
was
uh
what was interesting about the word
is that it has denial built into it
because the state department was very
saying that things that this is a
baseless accusation these are baseless
charges right and and the expectation
was that these
particular weapons if they were used
one of their advantages was this was
ceaselessly written about one of the
advantages of biological weapons is that
it's very hard to
determine whether these things happen
spontaneously because disease is endemic
to a country or whether they happen
because some other foreign
airplane has dropped feathers doped with
various diseases so i
nick baker let me just say i actually
decided to
yeah
i i want to quote your man uh tom
kennedy because i didn't we didn't
manage to fit it into the podcast we did
on this book right but it's very
striking the united states government uh
of course denied
they had planted this hemorrhagic fever
uh
no no less than a.m rosenthal the new
york times wrote a big story saying uh
there's no evidence for this charge at
all um
uh but you spoke to an ex-marine tom
kennedy who had been there must have
been an old man you talked in
in in manhattan and he said uh
that he had been told
on you know
must have been in the hospital that he
had a new disease hemorrhagic fever that
was carried by a tick
on a rat
and what he said to you was
among other things there was no history
of hemorrhagic evil in korea until its
use as a germ weapon
this was in an autobiographical note in
2015 only five years ago
i he said was one of those american
service members exposed to the secret
crime against humanity
that's pretty close to the horse's mouth
how do we weigh that
well
he's a guy who woke up with a fever one
day in korea
and he was medevaced out on a helicopter
and he was
and he was put in a
in a mash unit you know like in the tv
show and they said there are three
kwanzaa huts there's three hut 2 and hut
1. if you go into
hut three you're going to die
two you have a chance and hut one you're
okay and he went to hut three and he
worked his way through and and he
miraculously survived and then he was
discharged with a completely false
uh diagnosis
hemorrhagic fever
was something that just spontaneously
happened i think he's trying
his best to explain to himself something
immense that happened to him
as a young man in korea and it happened
to a number of men and there were people
who americans who died and
the bizarre thing is that
hemorrhagic fever is a hanta fever is is
is still a problem in korea and it was a
problem that was studied by
japanese
germ experts during the second world war
it was purified and intensified by them
and then the americans hired these same
germ warfare experts and then
miraculously somehow this fever appears
so i think there's a very strong case to
be made that it did a very that a small
and very evil
program happened
in somewhere around november of 1950 in
which the americans decided to use
japanese know-how to infect
people along a belt in korea i do think
that's true and i think one of the
victims was tom kennedy
can i add just a little bit of the
japanese background which i happen to
know only because
a wonderfully
marvelous writer gene gilman dear friend
of open source and
of all all good people uh gene gilman
wrote a book about basically about the
tokyo wartime
tokyo trials
of
of war crime that that never really took
place we all know about the nuremberg
trials of the germans
there were to be a sort of matching pair
of trials in tokyo which were
we were bluffed out of them in some
fashion because we would have we would
have been called on the carpet about the
nuclear weapons that we dropped on
nagasaki and hiroshima
so
but there was no question
and gene gilman documented in a
marvelous book that the japanese had
dropped all kinds of evil bugs on china
in the 30s before pearl harbor before
the world war
but the japanese were
they were the
world leaders in this technology and
part of the story you're revealing
or confirming is that the united states
copped onto this and we're using the
japanese in some fashion in this whole
project have i got it right i mean this
is a this is a global monstrous story
and and gene gilman really did a
beautiful job in hidden atrocities
telling the story and it's an absolutely
indispensable
book and i'm sorry that she's gone and
and i i i'm a heartbroken she would be
an incredible witness in covet in this
covert movement on she she's she was
the wife of matthew meselson who's also
a major figure in this book i quote both
of them in the book because they're both
so important to it
um but
what she what she chronicled
was the fact was something that other
people have talked about too but she did
the best job of it was that that there
was a desperate attempt to
get as many of the japanese
germ warfare experts as possible and get
them away from the russians and get them
into the american orbit and then hide
them from view
so what happened was that the russians
decided that
that the war crimes trial should take
place and that they they had a few
uh japanese germ experts
so they
held their own war crimes trials in in
kabharovsk
and there's a a full transcript of these
trials and it's really an appalling book
because there's no question that
everything that people are saying in
that book is
is absolutely it's a it's an absolute
transcript of what people actually said
and people and the and the
japanese scientists said i am so
re i so regret what i did in
it was it's just an amazing book
actually it's an amazing book but
what the result of it was that the
the russians were
upset worried
frightened of the united states as plans
and the united states meanwhile
had teams of experts interviewing all
these japanese
savants of
biological weaponry
and figuring out how best to take what
they had learned using they had done
experiments on humans so there was it
was absolutely priceless to their to
their way of thinking and pull those
things
back to camp dietrich
that kind of hub of germ warfare in the
united states and see if these
particular suite of diseases could be
further perfected and intensified
so that we could then apply them
in a hostile manner to the russians so
that was the flow
um quick parenthesis and then i want to
go someplace else but um
here we are
trump calling
coronavirus the china
the china uh
virus uh china every once in a while
mumbles under its breath that well maybe
this is an american
bio weapon maybe this is all politic uh
with your incredible depth
in the history what is possible
in the manipulation of the coronavirus
uh
even now since you
since you finished your book
well i think it uh
the history of germora fair in the
united states is a history of of
american scientists getting sick from
their own weapons lab accidents are just
a constant in in this book there's just
there's the national institute of health
there's a man who who decides he's going
to study q fever and he's going to study
it because it's a very
very dangerous and very worrisome
disease and he's going to weaponize it
so he takes it to the national institute
of health and immediately people start
getting sick there
and a person dies so this is a
a refrain of
the in the history of american
laboratory science that diseases get out
of laboratories the first thing that you
all just as if there's a murder the
in a couple the first thing you want to
ask is did the husband do it the first
thing you want to ask always if there is
an unexplained
exotic disease that breaks out in a
certain place you always want to look to
see if there's a laboratory in the area
so i think that
i do not think that the chinese
are involved in some sort of
evil plan to
cook up a germ weapon
they are like the americans very
concerned about getting a lucrative
vaccine for various viruses
and
they
and all of the american
laboratories were doing the same kind of
work the national institute of health
was paying the chinese to do this kind
of work
the fact is that it may or may not be
something that happened in a laboratory
but the first thing you want to do
is ask the people who are in charge of
the laboratory to open their freezers
and their notebooks
and
explain what happened and that hasn't
happened so
i want to digress nick because
as you're saying at the outset
this is a a detective story a historical
inquiry but it's also
it's as we
why we love nick baker is that there's a
lot of nick baker in it too would you
just read
a paragraph and i'll bet you'll find it
uh
in uh i think it's page
um
225
[Music]
but you're talking about your method
your barn your house your wandering your
dogs your wife
your weather uh there you are in maine
but uh
why do you write these books
this is a the book is so this chapter be
the title of the chapter is april 15
2019 monday each chapter is
entitled by the day of the week and i
just had gotten very wound up and had
come i'd sort of half revealed my theory
about what happened
with this these mysterious 700 voles
that dropped from the sky and stuff
and then
i ran out of steam i mean every day i
tried to write something and then i
would get exhausted and be done
so the next day starts
the edges of old secrets are blurred and
the middle is spongy and there are
frangible bits of recorded truth spread
around in the secrets like pieces of
thin ceramic
it's raining on tax day i've been awake
thinking about japan's rice crop
and then i have a few other fragments
and then i i go i go upstairs
come back downstairs and then i then i
make a note i just gotta say you do some
of your best work on on the staircase
nick
that's so nice of you chris
upstairs i thought
what do i really want from a book
i want truth in every paragraph i want
surprises i want to sense that
everything is not hopeless that we can
do better i want to sense that life is a
complicated mixture of emotions and
inconsistencies
life is a sandwich
i want to include or simulate
the pleasure of eating a sandwich
and then i finally say and i gotta get
to this because i can't i
cause the dogs are so important to me
when i woke up whenever it was hours ago
now i guess i reached out with my hand
and found that cedric one of the two
dachshunds had scooted up so that he was
elongatedly sleeping between m
and me my hand found his paw i held his
paw for a while and felt the braille of
joy of his paw pads
nick this is so wonderful i have to
acknowledge that there are nasty critics
out there who can't imagine why you you
write that sort of stuff in a serious
book but
it to me it's where you grab
all of us at four o'clock in the morning
puzzled
uh
uh
just
off beat uh i mean off the message
uh really concerned there's so much that
we know in detail and it's so vastly
much more that we
haven't the foggiest way to
get our
arms around or heads around emotional
mysteries metaphysical mysteries
political mysteries is trump going to
rebound
in in this november uh
but you're you're groping there for all
of us and i i i love it there's another
piece of that i'd love you to read from
um
and that is simply i mean you're
reviewing the this grotesque machine
in american life american government uh
to kill people
the more the better i mean this
incredible science of
of mass killing and destruction at the
same time like a lot of us you're kind
of madly in love with this country i
mean it's an amazingly fun interesting
lively
changeable
uh
endlessly delightful spot i mean read
read one of those passages when you talk
about
the context of all this craziness
well i
i thank you for asking me to do that and
i would have to find one
um i just want i i could i could give
you i could if you just yeah i i while
you tell while you find the page number
i just want to say i guess the the the
thing that excited me the the idea that
people some people there is a bad review
out there and it's very painful and i'm
sorry that it's there but it is there
is that i'm trying to do something a
little bit new here for gosh sakes i'm
trying to say there are plenty of
novels that you know look at the past
but then have the person who is
researching the past
eating a peanut butter sandwich and i've
done that and i like doing that but this
is
uh trying to
chronicle an actual life with all of its
minor trivial ups and downs
as it is mapping itself onto
the quest to find out momentous world
historical events
from 70 years ago and the two
timelines
kind of blur and merge recombinantly and
and separate and come back into focus
again and and that was i thought the the
contribution that the book was making
was to add
a little bit of
genuine truth real real
felt reality and moods to the historical
quest historians are not robots
i am i'm not a professional historian
but i have now written a couple of books
of history and i happen to know that
there are times when you feel
you're on top of it you feel you're the
world's expert on some tiny thing and
then there's some times when you feel
completely out of your depth and also
when there's just so many facts swarming
in your mind that you cannot
possibly
find your way through them and those
moods all those moods of confusion and
of grief
and of frustration when secrets are
withheld are all part of the process so
we have to i think have that kind of
soundtrack of
the actual historian's voice
as well as the
larger band of the account of what
happened
what's the page number well said uh 331
and 332 you go from the sort of
nightmare to the the dreamscape starting
with um
uh jfk and then comes kennedy uh we're
in vietnam
uh but but carry on onto
page three
332
okay well right so i was talking about
kennedy and
and kissinger and uh things that we know
about a little bit sometimes and then it
i i work myself up into these well
either i love the paragraph before and
then comes kennedy
and then comes kennedy who approves
defoliation and food denial and
operation mongoose kennedy appoints
henry cabot lodge to be ambassador to
vietnam
ambassador lodge becomes filled with a
murderous sort of petulance in saigon
and writes to dean rusk and robert
mcnamara in june 1964.
it would help here and possibly in laos
and thailand if there were some screams
from north vietnam that they had been
hit lodge says there must be a number of
different ways to make them scream he
mentions rockets employed on the pretext
that they were returning fire one method
he offers is redacted lodge uses the
word scream
four times in one telegram
then comes the gulf of tonkin incident
and rolling thunder
the war is in a new phase thanks to the
president's great decisions lodge wrote
to clark clifford delighted about the
bombing
more thunder endless thunder
anything that flies on anything that
moves said kissinger
relaying nixon's orders
then comes a space break thank goodness
a little moment to breathe
sometimes i don't believe in the history
of the united states now this is when i
say that i'm not saying as a general
rule every day of my life every hour of
every day but
i don't believe that this place deserves
to have any sort of moral standing in
the world as a country it has been the
source of incalculable disruption
i understand that americans individually
have done good things paintings sitcoms
songs cars
toasters
locomotives
buildings bridges billboards sunglasses
topiary dad's steps casseroles
no hitters corn mazes
speeches
ad campaigns
youtube videos
the new yorker of the katherine white
and e.b white era is a great american
achievement no question i always go back
to the mid-century new yorker and
there's john singer sergeant
operation sphinx this homegrown american
planned to kill five million human
beings in the space of weeks almost all
of them civilians just too awful to
think about
you'll have to read the book to see what
operation sphinx was
yeah thank you
thank you for no hitters on that list
i mean what could be more beautiful
and i don't even you know fully
understand baseball but but when you get
into that zone and you're far into a
game and and the sound of the baseball
hitting the mid it's just so
it's there's so much conviction there
it's so american
so
how do we reconcile these things but i
really we don't uh
i still i'm always
we've had so many good conversations
over the years
and a lot of them have this uh
uh it's not simple-minded in the least
but it is very appreciative it's very
grateful i was listening to one uh in
which you talked about the character
paul chowder who has a lot of things in
common with you but he was talking about
verse and what the hell is wrong with
four beat kipling verse but also leading
to the point that and you suggested
what you just read but
is there anything more glorious even in
poetry than the american songs of the
mid-century and was there ever
in our real lifetimes uh a more moving
part
than
lawrence hart larry hart as you know who
wrote songs with uh roger richard rogers
but also hoagy carmichael we were
speaking of
you know hoagie carmichael's song for
which you wrote the music to skylight
just an absolutely perfect poem or um
uh
george gershwin i mean ira gershwin
george's lyricist but um someday he'll
come along
the man i love uh
unbelievably wonderful poetry and again
that's the
the boy nick baker in in all of us who's
not the least simple-minded but uh
conflicted shall we say
i want to hear more about you
less about the weapons more about nick
baker
well i think the reason that sometimes
that you i want to write a book first of
all
yes to all that you're saying about song
lyrics and poetry and the american
inventiveness and the comedic
playfulness of internal rhyming which
carries on now in hip-hop i mean there's
there's tremendous ingenuity that's
being displayed a a kind of sleight of
mouth that is that is happening that's
very characteristic of
of this
real american originality of
inventiveness of of of rhyme and
and metrical sophistication and all it
continues so it's not as if
we are looking back at this right right
good morning landmass it's all happening
we're in the middle of it and rap i mean
there's no end to the to the
to the dance of words in in in in good
rap
so um
but but as far as
what i like to do is i of course want to
write about happy people and and
and
i want to write books that are evidence
for why
life is is worth living and good and but
there are these kind of chasms that open
up and that in in history and they're un
unpleasant and unfortunate they're not
just unfortunate they're terrifying and
one of them was world war ii and then
the cold war that immediately followed
it and i just
uh sometimes think that i it's my job to
write about those things and try to
figure out a way to heal over them or to
make them by understanding them
makes them less distracting so that i
can get back to writing about
why straws float or
you know
whatever little tiny things that are
actually
part of the
delicate texture of ongoing existence
and which is what i really
have always been drawn to and what i was
i've nabakov taught me that is you
is the this gossamer fabric of
lived life that were in the mid stuff
that's the that's what's really
important but
but sometimes
you know there's a crack a fissure that
opens in front of you and it's it's like
a disaster movie you know
and what is it it's
a piece of history that is so awful that
you cannot ignore it and so i sometimes
write a book about that in order to sort
of get past that thing and make a bridge
bridge beyond it
and i can i remind uh people listening
and watching that you're invited to
submit your own questions and answer
questions for nick baker to answer uh
you wanted to submit the answers too
that would be very helpful for me
um you get royalties for that too uh if
dania dame
has a question or two questions
uh one serious one not so much first
what part of you
nick baker do you think allows you to
write books that slow down time and
action so extremely as in the mezzanine
or a box of matches and now the serious
question your protagonist in the
anthologist that's our friend
paul chowder sometime podcast or two he
likes to sing a song i'm in the barn i'm
in the barn i'm in the barn in the
afternoon
i've been
it's been bothering me for years to
write what is the tune how does the song
go thank you
it's kenya well that is a friendly
question i'm in the barn i'm in the barn
i'm in the barn in the afternoon
that's the way it was in the barn
that's the answer to the second question
the first question why
how do you write books that slow down
time i think that
everybody who's writing a book is trying
to slow down time somehow or other is
just a any time you you take something
and lift lift it up in into the foyers
of your own intention attention and
think about it and turn it around
um it's it's a momentary parenthesis
that's been built around that object or
that social moment whatever it is
that transaction and that is and so it
is it is a slowing down of time a
sentence
has these you know wonderful little
breath marks semicolons commas dashes in
them and all of those
the kind of machinery of chuffing and
huffing and puffing are
all basically ways of
taking your your
your overly eager
leaping mind and putting it on a track
and saying just think your way along
this with me now
slowly and you know and it's almost
inevitable if you
write a sequence of words
um
that other people have to follow
they are slowed down because we
we actually are very good at parallel
processing and doing so i i think
i'm just doing what everybody wants to
do but i
it feels so good that i maybe do it a
little more and i also dispense with the
other stuff somewhat i sometimes get rid
of the
the the uh
larger spine of a plot and and just
leave and leave there
the the
slowed down
um worm trails of the
of the thoughts that i've had yeah yeah
yeah you're teaching us something here
nick i wonder who taught you you you
credited
uh earlier but
who who does that it starts going down
is thinking actually how we think and
how distractible and how multi-level our
process really is
i think it was well the the person who
first did it for me was i was i took i
audited the class when i was in high
school and one of the one of the stories
that was in the textbook in the class
was an ibalkov story and it was
uh and it had
[Music]
oh i don't know practically every
paragraph had this moment where
the paragraph would you'd be going along
at a normal rate of speed and then
[Music]
and it's just as if you're in this
described world that is it's it's a
surreally it's this it's surrealized
normalcy is what it is
and um it was very exciting and i
thought this is
this guy
is doing something that none of the
science fiction writers none of the
uh suspense writers that i'd read had
was able to do so
um i
so was the buck off that that took me
off and it's
two to nothing for
the great lad
but you know he has faults he was an
arrogant person and he didn't like
dostoyevsky
and stuff like that but he was um just
he his most vulnerable self was when he
would just be writing about you know a
rainstorm reaching a certain tree or
uh he he wrote
well and and and there were people who
followed from him i mean i i think that
updike learned a huge amount from him i
think he learned a lot from proust i
think bruce learned a lot from george
eliot actually there's all there's a
long tradition of it but but the 20th
century one of the beautiful things
about the 20th century is that it's the
century of observation and the and and
improvisation but but but these two
things that and that and it seemed
mysteriously to have happened most
uh
juicily in the united states
yeah interesting other questions here
robert rothstein
writes
i've read that the u.s bombed virtually
every city in town in north korea to the
extent that there was nothing left to
bomb if this is true then why was it
such a drive to develop a horrendous
biological weapon
the bombing campaign that's a very good
question the bombing campaign was
unsuccessful even though every single
village and every city was
burned not just bombed but burned the
entire was an attempt to burn an entire
country um it did not succeed because
the north koreans escaped
by living in caves so they spent years
in caves um
and that's and so the the idea was
though that they did
chinese were assisting them and we
didn't want that so
the final effort was to
frighten the chinese and make them go
away by dropping
these
very traditional looking bombs that were
actually leaflet bombs but they were
filled with
insects and the chinese made very
detailed accounts of all these different
insects
my suspicion is that that actually
happened but that the chinese charge
that those insects were doped with
diseases
was was falsified that it in fact was
what the americans called a deception
operation and it was baseless it was a
deniable
effort so they wanted to discourage
terrify
uh cause
unhappiness in
the area of china that was right on the
border of korea that was where these
events supposedly happened
and um
and that's i think what did happen
what question and also a message from
steve kinser saluting your work steve
kender wrote a remarkable book on fort
dietrich
and the general presupposition it is and
it's
we're not making it up is that
under douglas mcarthur's purview
the japanese
know
know-how
in german warfare was transferred to
fort detroit in maryland
where
mk ultra and other horrors could develop
and described in steve pence's wonderful
book on sydney weintraub was it
yeah
but
sydney
sydney leave yeah thank you and the name
of steve's book is
uh
assassin in chief or something
i want to say something about steve
kinser because
i i could not possibly have written this
book without the book this man
is a great explainer and it it's it's
impossible to describe how difficult it
is to
deal with something as complicated as
the cold war
and make it clear and this is what uh
stephen kinser has done in a whole bunch
of books amen one one after another he
all the shah's men
iran exactly
um and the dulles brothers and uh so one
book after another he is a master quoter
that's another talent that i think
people don't understand how important it
is there's an infinitive of things you
can quote
you can make a point with 87 different
things but if you choose the right quote
the paragraph sits the mind is
both moved along but comforted that some
learning has happened
and he does that
um
dale evans
as in roy rogers maybe
asked the question why is henry
kissinger still alive
oh god maybe we can we don't need to
answer that um
uh
and
lurie asks
or says i'm so glad you mentioned
floating straws ever since plastic stars
started going away i've been thinking
about
the paper straw and soda in a can
and
pizza passage
and the pizza passage in mezzanine
how are you liking the new breed of
paper storage
oh gosh well the the it you know it's
funny about trying to slow time down
which i tried to do in in in the
mezzanine using footnotes and
huge paragraphs of description and one
there was a footnote about the
floating straw so
some straws float some straws do not
float it has to do with whether they're
plastic or paper
and uh i thought well i've really
nailed this one it was like with a hot
air blower in in in uh restrooms you
know i thought really that's it it's
there's no nothing more to be said about
this but then time marches on and
and suddenly there's a political element
and
what do i think about the floating
straws of today or the
is um
basically i have very very little
experience with them i know too much
about them i don't know very much about
the current straws i think i'm i'm lost
in
80s straw time
but
i obviously have got to do some serious
research it's just that it's hard to go
to a restaurant and and
straws are completely unneces
unnecessary but they're part of their
joy they're joyful i mean they're
they're a miracle it was a kid i love
the idea that you could just simply
levitate your lip whatever liquid you're
drinking right to your mouth as if it's
in an elevator i love that
but um
i have a question nick and maybe you're
answering it as we go um
when you look at this
really
fascinating range of books you've
written
and some of them
some of them
in all of them something numerously
funny it's just
reflexive
and it's hard to account for but um
what's the pattern you see in in the
range from your soft porn to your deep
history and it's deeply thoughtful
uh human history to your
shall we say um
i don't want to say trivia but your your
microscopic examination of small things
but what who who is this guy nicholson
baker
who would have who would have been a
symphony bassoonist if he had
one percent more
talent talent a lot of 40 more talent um
well there's two
i could say that
you know
one thing that i do think is important
is to write every day and if you write
every day every day is a especially if
you ask yourself what's the best moment
of the day
new things are always
um
arising but i guess the theme
if i was going to be grand about it is
rescue
i like to
rescue
everyday life from the kind of neglect
of its everydayness i like to rescue the
idea that there's nothing more
completely over talked about than sex
and say well maybe there's more to be
said about even sex you know that we all
or
that um there was this book the rescue
in this book is that there were two very
nice
historians from toronto that wrote a
book about this and the book was panned
and
they
so were such wounded men because of this
process
and i thought that they had done a
really they'd written a really good and
useful book that part of what motivated
me to write this book was to rescue them
and one of them died before i
finished the book and while i was
writing the book the other one died
but always i want to bring
something out bring some aspect some
often just to some wayside
wildflower of
noticed
life
and i want to say that's me let's put a
frame around that let's talk about that
for a moment
um and
uh
all part of making a tasty sandwich
it's all if any you know what i found
with sandwiches and i've only discovered
this in the last couple of years is
anything you can make a sandwich out of
anything
i mean all because all you need is the
crunch the mixture of cold and warm and
and just a few different
kind of
incompatible layers and you have the the
sandwich joy you don't need meat i don't
my sandwiches don't have meat anymore
um you need some
you need some stuff sproutsy things but
you need some
greasy so i i've made potato sandwiches
today i had two
and i'm just gonna lay it out here two
spinach sandwiches i made spinach i put
them in a bun and i put some mustard on
it you take a bite of that and that is a
complete sandwich experience
listen deanna duff has a serious
question and it's part of the book um
can you please speak of how the freedom
of information act played into your
process
using a process allegedly to
further transparency
but protecting heinous secrets this is a
serious core and a political
uh impulse in your book i mean make this
damn thing work everything
don't you say everything older than 70
years old should be released
unmarked unquestioned and asked just put
it out there this word redaction just i
mean just say it and i just begin to
shiver all over i can't stand it it's a
euphemism it's
it's a terrible thing
there should be all i actually have a
more radical view which is all documents
older than 50 years
ought to be completely and totally
declassified with no redactions because
it's though they have entered the world
of history and they're no longer
state secrets now they are historical
bits of richness that we can
think about and learn and and if they're
mistakes we can learn from those
mistakes so that's the
didn't why didn't the
foia
get its job done
well it was a great law and it was it is
a good law it's a very good law and it
took a long time to get it passed
10 years i think
lyndon johnson signed it into law and at
almost immediately it began to
dislodge all kinds of secrets and
secrets began exploding out of
agencies like the air force and the
central intelligence agency and it was a
all the way through
the late 70s there was a tremendous
outpouring of knowledge about what had
happened in the cold war
and then in during the reagan era it
contracted right rules changed so
i
think we're living in a time in which
the
several important switches in the bank
of switches of the freedom of
information act of circuit breakers have
been simply shut off and we've got to go
back and actually enforce the law as it
is on the books flip all the circuit
breakers on and say let's learn
let's learn what's there i mean why
would i i guess the the fundamental
frustration of this book
is that
you know it's a 400 page book and all
the way all the time i was writing it
for all those eight 10 years
i was waiting
for a set of documents to be released
and
um maybe it's got to be done in a hurry
nick gary hart former senator from
colorado is on our program this week
talking about he was he and walter
monday were the last two survivors of
the church committee but they unearthed
a lot of evil stuff assassinations of
lumumba for
it's got to be put out um
but
at the very moment we're in
president
trump likes to say you know i have
powers that nobody knows about that you
don't know about i can do after
declaring a national emergency
and gary hart is saying well we better
damn well better find out
and talk about it what are those secret
powers uh
we're i think we're running out of time
though nick before we're done i want to
just want to credit
a dear friend of mine alexander theroux
who told me 35 67 years ago you want to
see a real writer
go get mezzanine by a guy named
nicholson baker and i did and he was
entirely right uh i rejoice in having
read i think all of your books and and
getting to know you ten more of these
interviews nick and we'll get to know
each other
well i i want to say i've learned a huge
amount from you and every every time we
talk i i feel i'm getting closer to
understanding myself and the outside
world so thank you
and i do want to look at i want to say
one thing one tiny victory
is here is a redacted document
that i dealt with for 10 years right and
it's a very important document from 1949
that's
a planned of how to deceive somebody but
it's all blacked out what's being
deceived here's the document that
mysteriously appeared in the mail the
very same document without a single
redaction
about two weeks before the book went to
press
the national archives
uh somehow got the pentagon to
to release this thing and it is the
beginning of the biological weapons arms
race between the americans and the
soviet union because it says the
americans are going to deceive the
soviet union into thinking that the
americans have come up with a super
toxic
germ weapon and once they do that then
the the russians are going to waste
their efforts trying to
build the same weapon well they did
waste their efforts in fact they did
build the weapon and we had a whole huge
mess
of of an arms race because of this plan
from 1949.
so you write you write a whole book
and there's all these frustrations in it
and documents that aren't released and
then mysteriously because the book
exists
one crucial document gets pried out at
the end
and that's it's all worth it
wow
wow that's news that's important
i think it is important i'm going to
post it on twitter because if it's
important you got to post it on twitter
nick baker
thank you
i think we ought to say thank you
especially to the harvard bookstore and
welcome our hostess
back
and say good night
thank you thank you so much chris thank
you thank you
thank you both so much this was truly
lovely um
so thank you both to both nicholson and
christopher thanks to all of you out
there for spending your evening with us
you can learn more about this important
book and purchase baseless uh my search
for secrets in the ruins of the freedom
of information act at the link in our
chat um or on harvard.com once this uh
closes um and on behalf of harvard
bookstore here in cambridge mass uh
thank you both and have a good night
keep reading and please everybody please
be well
thank you
bye thank you so much everybody take
care
here's a look at some publishing
industry news author and journalist gail
sheehy died last week at the age of 83.
she was a contributor